so hier nochmal der briefe euch leute er
glaubt dass becker leute herzlich
willkommen zu einem video von dem ich
nie gedacht hätte dass das so mal auf
meinem kanal erscheinen wird leute wenn
ihr meinen kanal der letzten zeit erfolg
gehabt dann wisst ihr dass ich fast
ausschließlich reactions gemacht habe
und es ist tatsächlich so dass ich ab
und zu schon mal gedacht habe jacksons
wirklich so das war's nicht aber was
anderes machen und ich so das bedürfnis
in mir hatte dass ich bisschen mehr so
mein eigenes privatleben mehr so von dem
was ich als person bin in meinen videos
reinbringen will aber dass das in so
einer art und weise passiert hätte ich
auch nicht gedacht aber hier sehen wir
jetzt heute ist wahrscheinlich eine
schnapsidee aber ich werde es in diesem
video heute einfach weil ich finde dass
dieses video das braucht dass das
erfordert möglichst frei und
ungeschnitten reden also ich werde auch
jetzt nicht gewisse sequenzen dreimal
aufnehmen oder so damit die optimale
vertont und betont sind wir einfach mal
ein bisschen freier sprechen einfach
auch wie gesagt weil es nach dem sinn
passt finde ich dass ich bisschen mehr
aus meinem leben erzählen leute ihr habt
das habt ihr den titel gesehen ja vor
einigen tagen es war der abend des
dreißigsten april bin ich zurück
gekommen abends sich versteht noch
trainieren mit einem kumpel ganz mieses
wetter so hat folge regnet ich bin kurz
nach mitternacht zurück gekommen und
stand unten an meiner tür von dem haus
in dem ich wohne und ja es ist ein haus
in dem ich heiße wieviel zehn wohnungen
sind oder zwölf wohnung so fünf
stockwerke mit mehreren wohnungen pro
stockwerk und so und dann hingen da an
der tür ein brief angeklebt ja unten an
der eingangstür also wo alle durchgehend
hängen dieser brief und ich komme da so
kurz vor mitternacht an denken okay was
ist das jetzt so ungewöhnlich eigentlich
niemand hängen sonst briefe unten an die
eingangstür von unserem haus macht
keiner so kein postbote oder sowas hängt
ja immer sinnvoll wie war das mit so
breiten klebestreifen wir gleich sehen
werdet festgeklebt lies mal
und ja das ist in der phase passiert wo
ich gerade das video ein hund für 40
stunden adoptieren gedreht habe
dieses video 40 stunden hund adoptieren
ist vor zwei tagen auf einem kanal oder
gegangen und da habe ich bei mir gehabt
für 40 stunden sheltie und ja lieber
sprechen mich dann sehr gewundert als
auf diesen brief stand
ich zeige es euch war an den süßen
unbekannten mit dem stellte das war so
ich hätte mir nie irgendwas in der form
passiert wird immer noch so ein bisschen
die worte wenn ich rede weil das
irgendwie sowas passiert passiert
heutzutage eigentlich doch nicht mehr
wirklich oder heutzutage wo man sich
eigentlich so oft über so online dating
plattformen jetzt konkrete taten erfasst
schnell verdammt die hat linda gray
darüber was es alles gibt kennen lernt
oder in clubs oder so irgendwie so auf
der straße ansprechen oder auf andere
art und weise kennen lernt ist noch bis
bisschen seltener geworden hab ich's
gefühl leute dementsprechend war sehr
überrascht darüber und dann habe ich das
meiner in story geteilt und meine
freundin das gesehene waren so okay ich
hatte und habe ich mit ein paar leute
geschrieben und eine person von diesen
leuten luca also konkreter luca hat mir
die idee gegeben
mach doch mal das video das ich dachte
mir okay dann habe ich eine weile hin
und her überlegt und dachte mir komm mal
so wenn du hattest jetzt bei diesem und
4 5 420 stunden video so viel spaß
einfach weil es ein bisschen mehr
abwechslung drin so kann ein bisschen
mehr so von deiner eigenen person zeigen
von deinen eigenen hobbys ich mag hunde
zum beispiel sehr warum nicht einfach
weiter in diese richtung gehen und
einfach mal auch eine relativ radikalen
schritt der der ja dieses video ist auch
mal gehen das heißt einfach mal auch
sachen aus dem eigenen leben preisgeben
die meisten natürlich preisgeben würden
und ja die man spreche jetzt dieses
video leute und ich werde euch auf
diesen brief vorlesen und ich werde
glaube ich tatsächlich einfach mal
darüber so vielleicht so eine kleine
video serie starten so weil man so was
ist heutzutage doch so selten und ich
glaube dass es für viele leute
interessant einfach mal so zu sehen okay
was passiert da jetzt genau wie verläuft
das und das mache ich jetzt ich lese ich
diesen brief war und ich werde euch auch
sollte es da zum treffen kommen was ich
jetzt versuchen werde weil das mädchen
stets junge frau die diesen brief
geschrieben hat tatsächlich auch sehr
sehr nett geschrieben hat dann welche
von diesem treffen berichten
daten video aber schon jetzt erstmal in
diesem verein es ist echt unglaublich
leid ich denke dass wir noch nicht wir
doch mal gespannt wie sie darauf
reagieren wird
dass ich erst mal überhaupt youtube
macher und b falls sie mitbekommt dass
das irgendwie so auch von mir so
dokumentiert wurde in so einem video na
ja auf jeden fall leute
der brief lautet ich zeige ihnen nicht
auch gleich hey du wunderst dich
bestimmt wie so ich dir schreibe du bist
mir beim spazierengehen positiv
aufgefallen und als ich zufällig gesehen
habe wo du wohnst wollte ich mir die
chance nicht entgehen lassen vielleicht
hast du ja mal lust einen kaffee trinken
zu gehen fragezeichen meld dich gerne
und dann ihre handynummer und ihr name
das habe ich jetzt martin sieht an der
stelle hier doch mal hat er briefe euch
leute
ich bin glaube ich denke das ist
wirklich drunter steht dann die mit dem
cover die mit dem chihuahua aber ja und
da habe ich überlegt leute wer könnte
das gewesen sein da habe ich so nie in
story dazu gemacht weil ich mir dachte
so irgendwie muss ich das jetzt
bearbeiten und so ich meine wir so
youtuber instagram sind ja auch immer so
ein bisschen auf der suche nach content
bis ich meine wir sind immer auf der
suche danach etwas spannendes
interessantes zu finden wenn irgendwas
anders in unserem leben passiert und wir
halt so drauf sind dass wir auch gerne
mal sachen teilen und gerne noch ein
bisschen mehr von uns preisgeben
dann post mit teilweise wasser gesagt
also ich das gemacht gepostet und dann
zu diesem posten hat so dazu geschrieben
ich weiß gar nicht wer das ist weil es
mir auch wirklich nicht eingefallen ist
beziehungsweise ich wusste es nicht
sicher aber dann habe ich nochmal weiter
rum überlegt und dann ist mir eine sache
ein gefallen und zwar war es tatsächlich
so dass ich mit sam zurückkamen von
irgendwem abend spazieren oder so glaube
ich und dann geradezu von meiner haustür
stand und dann sie just ein zwei meter
bevor ich meine haustür erreiche eine
eine junge frau ist ein mädchen einmal
vorbei gelaufen ist und ich habe mich
null mehr an ihr gesicht erinnert ich
habe mich nur daran erinnert dass ich
mir so vage daran erinnert dass du mir
dachte ja die ist wie sieht eigentlich
ganz nett aussieht sympathisch so
sympathisch man kann sich unterhalten
kann und dass sie so einen kleinen hund
hatte so ein ganz kleiner und ist
nämlich aufgefallen aber ich möchte so
die gab es ja noch mal viele kleider als
und sam ist schon so ein mittelgroßer
hund als stativ und dann dachte mir so
wahrscheinlich war die dass alle auf
installieren so gesagt jan hat diese
zufällig gesehen wo du wohnst weil ja
ich habe mir dazu geschrieben hatte dass
ich mich nicht an die personen erinnern
konnte weiß ich nehme mir nicht kontakt
gepostet haben alle gedacht hey das ist
ein starker us talkerin aber ist das
nicht
ist es nicht sondern es ist tatsächlich
ich glaube es ist muss ich muss diese
person gewesen sein
das war wirklich ein toller vor meiner
haustür liegt ihm an mir vorbei und es
wahnsinn ist crazy ich glaube wir haben
uns nicht mehr wie groß in die augen
geschaut oder so oder wenn es irgendwie
auch nur angelächelt oder so dass er
irgendwie intensiver kontakt da war dass
das war gar nicht so aber aus
irgendeinem grund hat sam den ring
merken sehr gut gemacht und kenne alle
und dann kann man ihr dann danach die
idee diesen brief daran zu machen was
ich persönlich man sagen und das haben
auch die leute von mir geschrieben also
für freunde von mir erstmal gut heiße
weil das die aktion zeigt erst mal okay
die frau hat krones so die ist auch
bereit malen ungewöhnlichen weg zu gehen
was ich auch eigentlich cool finde ich
meine es ja ein gutes zeichen wenn ich
mir vorstelle ob ich das irgendwie so
machen würde bei irgendwem eder was ich
interessant finde ich mir gar nicht so
sicher ob ich das ob das in meinem
instrumentarium drin wäre das
unvorstellbar erklärte dass das kind
tatsächlich vorstellen könnte eigentlich
nicht aber sie konnte das charmant ja
leute ich nehme dieses video jetzt auf
am dritten mai den späten nachmittag
frühen abend als sind schon 123 tage
vergangen
das ist schon so eine kleine pause sie
wird wahrscheinlich denken dass
irgendein anderes den zettel ab gemacht
hat oder dass das keine ahnung ich kein
interesse haben oder so aber ich muss
sagen weil ich mich ja nicht mal mehr
gesicht erinnern konnte nur noch eine
vage erinnerung hatte dass ich mir
dachte sie seien wie attraktiv gewesen
habe ich dann mal die nummer 1 geben
natürlich wäre ich das bild jetzt
einwenden leute wegen bilderschatz aber
die ist tatsächlich nein es ist eine
sie ist hübsch so ist eigentlich auch
meinen mein typ so und ja
dementsprechend werde ich jetzt mal
dementsprechend leute und jetzt habe ich
schon länger gedauert als ich gedacht
hätte ich hätte gesagt dass das video so
lange ich nehme schon 14 minuten auf
kraft gibt es fünf minuten youtube nun
aber seien aber ja leute schreibt mir
jetzt an diesem punkt marotten die
kommentare rein was ihr an meiner stelle
machen würde was wäre aber eure reaktion
was würdet ihr euch denken ist es gut
ist schlecht bewertet ihr tier positiv
überrascht was würdet ihr machen an
meiner stelle und ratet mir auch mal
konkret an was ich jetzt machen soll in
diesem moment ich glaube nämlich ich
werde mal darauf eingehen
und ja wie ich anfangs gesagt habe ihr
mal schreiben und sagen hey hier ist
sebastian mit dem feld die den chelsea
hatte für 24 stunden und dementsprechend
dann einfach hier mal auf youtube für
euch dokumentieren was passiert in so
einem fall der glaube ich nicht viele
überhaupt mal passiert im leben oder
also mir ist das noch nie passiert ich
kenne keine freunde denen das passiert
ist deswegen ist es bestimmt für euch
vielleicht auch interessant sind das mal
anzuschauen
wir machen jetzt aber so eine serie
daraus auf idee von luca was eine gute
idee ist muss ich sagen okay leute
kurzer nachtrag aus dem schnitt aus
zweierlei gründen eher grund nummer eins
ist das mein youtuber herz natürlich
geblutet hat als ich gesehen habe dass
dieses video nicht auf zehn minuten ist
dementsprechend wir es jetzt hier mit
der wahrscheinlich erreichen zweiten
sollte habe ich etwas wichtiges zu
erzählen und zwar leute ich habe mir
direkt schon update eigentlich endlich
wieder zum zweiten video aber egal jetzt
hier ich habe mir tatsächlich ein herz
gefasst und habe dann noch während ich
das video geschnitten habe was jetzt
kann eben schon gesehen habt die
nachricht ich geschrieben und habe
gesagt hey hier ist sebastian mit dem
schild also danke für deine nachricht so
fand ich lustig so fand ich auch
außergewöhnlich und wir können gerne mal
einen kaffee trinken geht und dann kam
tatsächlich eine ganze weile erstmal
nichts zurück so ne halbe stunde stunde
da habe ich schon bist du okay da habe
ich danach geschaffen
übrigens sowieso wenn die pause jetzt
lang vorkommen so ich muss das jetzt
erst mal in ordnung aber danach hat sich
dann auch ganz wollten und jetzt mit dem
schreiben und sieht aus als wenn wir uns
die tage mal treffen
also dem seine leute eure gedanken und
in die kommentare und taktiert
vorgestellt das video ab und hier könnt
ihr meinen kanal abonnieren wenn er
diese story weiter verfolgen wollte
würde mich sehr freuen ist natürlich
kostenlos ihr kennt ja das prinzip
ich bin an der schule raus bleibt stabil
bleibt die mit dem zschopauer an alle
mädels bleibt der mit dem schild an alle
jungs und ja bis in zwei tagen